hey there townscapers and welcome back
to the channel if this is your first
time here of course i want to give you a
really big welcome and i want to thank
you for stopping by as always any
support that i receive is greatly
appreciated i want to thank you all so
much for the love and the support the
channel just hit 1 000 subs and i'm
really excited about that i can't thank
you guys enough also while we're here i
have a new paint over contest entry this
submission was created by blue mizel and
i really really love this one because it
tells the story and it has a mystical or
a fairy tale type vibe to it if you will
i love the way the textures were edited
i love the way all the characters
replaced i just love everything about it
so make sure you guys check out the
entry in the gallery there are more
screenshots also make sure that you go
show blue some love their social media
links are in the description below so
make sure you follow them on instagram
and subscribe to them on youtube and
just show them some love see what
they're doing blue is a really great
artist so with that being said we're
just gonna jump right into today's
tutorial just a quick note this tutorial
is for pc only i'm not sure if there is
a way to change the palette on mobile or
switch i have searched my oscar
stahlberg folder on my phone and i did
not find the town color file so i'm not
really sure how to do that or if there's
a way to even change it so as of now
until there's some kind of miracle and
someone finds a solution unfortunately
this will only be for computer users for
pc users um so yeah changing the color
palette is very easy all you need is
photo editing software there are several
to choose from and many of them are free
and sometimes they're already installed
on your computer for example paint today
i'll be using photoshop but you could
also use paint or other similar programs
as those programs allow you to use
layers as well which is the method that
i will be using today also i will leave
some links below for some free photoshop
alternatives also if you want to check
those out a good one that i would
recommend is [ __ ] but there are others
out there for you to try if you just
want to explore a little bit so the
first thing you want to do is you want
to find your townscaper folder and
that's where your town palette file is
found so for windows users you can find
that in your app data folder for a mac
the folder is called library and the
townscaper folder is called
com.oscarstalberg.townscaper
i will leave a link that i use to figure
this out down below so that you will
have a reference on how to find it so
let's just go ahead
and get started on this
in order to access your townscaper
folder you want to go into the file
location that will be in the description
if you're on mac if you're on windows
you want to open your run program and
you can do that by hitting r windows or
windows r and the run program will open
see right here where it says open it
says app data sometimes it won't say
that if it doesn't all you have to do is
add it in there you just put percentage
and app data app data another percentage
symbol and hit okay if it puts you in
roaming all you have to do is click the
app data link and you'll see three
folders local local low and roaming you
want to open local low then you want to
open oscar stahlberg then you want to
open townscaper so it's recommended that
you have a backup folder as you can see
here i have one in my townscaper folder
when you open it you see i have a backup
of the base palette i have an orange
palette i have a pink palette and i have
a purple palette now you don't
necessarily have to back it up because
townscaper will automatically replace it
but if you want to be safe all you have
to do is copy it and then you can save
it in a backup folder like i did here on
the base palette or you can just paste
it somewhere wherever you can find it so
after you do that what you want to do is
you want to open the original town
palette file and i'm going to open mines
with photoshop
[Music]
so i'm going to make this a little
bigger right now it's at 100 but the png
is really small for some reason i'm not
really sure why it's so small a good
size would be about
11 000 or 10 000 i'm going to start with
10 000 let's try that okay so you see
here i have the entire color palette
there is about 15 colors
so what you want to do is you want to
take your first layer or your base
palette and you just want to go ahead
and rename it you can just double click
and change the name i'm going to change
mines to base and i'm going to make it
all caps then after you do that you want
to make several layers of the white
block now this gray block at the end it
won't show up when you
make the town palace you don't have to
worry about that so i click the marquee
tool and i click the white color block
and i'm going to copy it and then i'm
going to paste about 14 blocks if i'm
not mistaken there's 15 colors on the
palette i could be miscounting that so
don't copy that gray block copy this
white block that way you can cover the
entire palette with white blocks so
that's what i'm going to do right now
i'm going to go ahead and paste these
and
let's see what we get here
[Music]
i added about 14 layers because the 15th
block will be the white block and the
gray block is not going to show up in
game and you just want to take each
layer and i would recommend honestly
doing it in order uh so that way you
could just start from the top and work
your way from the bottom what i've
noticed is if you're not careful
sometimes i would end up placing the
layers out of order so when i go to the
list on the side here i would see all my
layers and they wouldn't be in numerical
order it would be 1 2 3
7
4 15 or something like that like they
would not be in order and especially if
you want to place your colors in the
same order as you found them however you
set up your your set of colors or
whatever set of hues that you decided to
use you want to be able to make sure
that they flow properly so placing them
in order will not only prevent any
confusion that could happen but it could
also help you prepare it so that your
colors would lay out properly it just
really depends on your preference so
after you add your extra blocks in you
want to make sure that the gray one
isn't covered you want to make sure that
the original white isn't covered even
though if you covered it with a white it
wouldn't matter it will still show up as
white if you want to get rid of white
all together it changes to a totally
different color that's fine as well then
you want to
pick a layer you'll see here that i
actually click layer 2 to start off but
don't pay attention to that somehow
somewhere there's an extra layer in
there so just ignore that when you place
your layers you want to make sure that
they're all in order
and you want to open that layer up
[Music]
and then you just start choosing your
colors use the color picker and just
scroll through it through the hues and
pick whatever colors you want you can
use the swatches if you want to if you
have any hex numbers in mind you can use
those something that i would recommend
if you want a little bit of variety and
you want some more color or you just
want to work with a certain range of
colors like on the spectrum i really
recommend going to this website it's
called work with color and weber color
is pretty cool because it basically lays
out the entire color spectrum like right
at your fingertips they have a color
picker wheel
they have a list where you can go by
color names like literally any other
color that you can think of you can even
make your own colors if you want to
using the color mixer feature i really
like this website and i just found it
randomly i just typed in
hex codes for colors and it popped up on
google so very useful resource if you're
looking for a little bit of variety as
far as colors are concerned so
i'm going to pick some colors
and i'm going to use them to change the
color palette
just a little bit of advice that i want
to give you if you
plan to copy and paste and add different
colors to each layer what i would
recommend is just copying all of your
color codes you just use the clipboard
feature if you're on pc that's what i do
i copy all of them and then i use the
clipboard feature and then i just
remember what order i went in so i know
how i want the colors to show up on the
palette and then you're going to go back
into your program and you're going to
pick each square i'm going to start from
the bottom because the last color that i
picked was the the darkest hue and you
just want to go in you want to change
that overlay and for this palette i want
to keep a white block just to give it a
little bit of variety to give it a
little bit of contrast so i'm going to
keep the white block and i'm going to
start from the block after that and i'm
just going to change every color until i
fill every block
[Music]
to avoid having to do all of this over
again i would really recommend saving
this uh
this has a template for photoshop you
would save it as a psd you would want to
save it so whenever you open it up you
would have your layers
[Music]
and when you're done changing your
colors you can save it as a png so let's
go ahead and save this
i'm going to save it as a png i'm going
to change the name to green palette so
that way it can be held in a folder as a
backup and i don't have to make a green
palette again or at least not one with
these types of green so i'm going to put
that in my backups folder i even made an
extra folder for it and i'm going to put
green palette and then i'm going to save
it as a png so now what you want to do
is you want to go into your townscaper
folder let me go on ahead and close this
out you want to go into your townscaper
folder and you want to make sure that
the original townscaper file is gone the
original tile palette file is gone go
into your backups and copy your new file
for for mines it would be green palette
so i'm gonna copy green palette and then
i'm gonna go to townscaper i'm gonna go
back to textures and i'm gonna paste it
make sure that you rename it because if
you don't rename it it's not going to
show up so you want to make sure that
you rename that file to town palette and
it's all one word make sure you get rid
of the space or otherwise townscaper
won't read it and it will generate a new
file for you and you'll have your
original colors so after we do that
we'll open townscaper and we'll check
out the results
[Music]
so this is what it looks like by the way
this is one of my favorite builds if you
want to see the original build i'll link
it in the description and maybe put it
in a card or something but yeah this is
it and i actually like this one better
to be honest with you it's just
something about the shades of green that
really draws you in if you enjoyed this
video please leave a comment please
share this video and please leave a like
as it would really help me out in the
youtube algorithm i would really really
appreciate it if this is your first time
here again thank you so much for
stopping by i hope that you enjoyed this
video and i hope it was enough to get
you to stick around and see what else i
got going on so with that being said
thank you thank you thank you and i will
see you guys next time
[Music]
bye